[Música]
o zezé entrou num o dia do soldado
olho vivo na lembrança do vozão
a urgência ano
[Música]
neste corpo que a mo yan lançar não
chora sangras caminho cursan
tu não é senão todos v curta que eu é
[Música]
hoje jean não os dos outros
ae
[Música]
podes vir quando quiser entrar desta
casa que já na avenida
ai ai ai fica nos lançamos por cor
talvez certa antes de sair já
afinam nossa história de amor são os
voltas do pai é prazer
isto tudo é janeiro não pode esperar
or ficar hoje já
[Música]
soutto toró
o hu olho
[Aplausos]
então eu vou aproveitar para agradecer o
convite e agradeço a minha piscina
piscina vacilar como acompanhou hoje e é
toda a produção do deck mating
desabrigadas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
naquela diesel sem andar você me dizia
sempre o que é viver melhor naquela mesa
eu contava histórias que hoje namora eu
guardo em saída ocorre naquela mesa eu
juntava jeito e com dava governo fez de
manhã e nos seus olhos era até do brilho
que mais que sua filha eu vigas ufam
eu não sabia que não ia tanto uma mesa
num canto uma casa no jardim
se eu soubesse o quanto dói a filha está
a dor não do iva não é assim
agora restam beija da sala e hoje
ninguém mais fala do seu ângulo ruim
naquela mesa está faltando ela que
saudar deus a doer
i brincar lá mesmo esta volta do euro
lei e saudado pelo estado horang
[Música]
naquela benzeu sentar você e me dizia
ser o que é viver melhor naquela mesa eu
contava histórias que hoje namora eu
guardei sair gols naquela mesa eu
juntava jean e contava gol tendo cabeça
manhã e nos seus olhos era tanto o
brilho de mais que sua filha e eu fiquei
fã eu não sabia que não ia ter uma mesa
nunca uma casa no jardim
se eu soubesse o quanto vai o filho está
adotando o windows não doía
efe agora resta uma missa mensal e hoje
ninguém mais fala do seu pai do im
naquela mesa está faltando ela que é
soldado dela está a doer
i gala mesmo está faltando o eu sou da
deus está do enem
naquela mesa está faltando ela ea
saudade de estado era em mim naquela
mesa estavam dando erro
ia soltar
o estado é ai mim
i
[Música]
obrigado a ficar ótimo